I can't believe I'm saying it but Carlos
ocelot Rodriguez has stepped down as CEO
of G2 Esports he was initially on an
eight-week suspension from the org but
after g2's application for valorant
partnership was revoked it seems like
perhaps the board decided that the
damage here from his recent actions was
just too severe so let's dive in and
take a look at this thing what happened
who's at fault and what's next for both
Carlos and G2
foreign
hey guys before we get into the video
just wanted to ask you to please
subscribe to the channel ring the
notification Bell and if you have a good
time today why not leave a like on the
video it really does help you can also
check out our twitch Channel at
twitch.tv slash the score Esports where
we've got new live content all the time
we'd love to see you in chat okay on
with the video so if you missed my video
last week on the initial reaction to
Carlos's tape video tweet you can check
that out if you want the full context of
what happened but essentially here's The
quick summary Carlos tweeted a video of
himself celebrating g2's World
Championship that showed him partying
with Andrew Tate Tate has become an
extremely controversial figure online
for his views on women and his paid
Hustlers University program but in
August he became an Optics problem too
big for major platforms to ignore and he
was banned from most of them after
ocelot's initial tweet he doubled down
then made a seemingly forced statement
while continuing to like tweet
supporting Tate or downplaying the video
G2 did apologize and said Carlos would
be taking eight weeks of unpaid leave
but then Riot did something pretty
unexpected as first reported by one pv's
now and confirmed by dot esports's
George Gettys Riot held an emergency
meeting and then removed G2 from their N
A valorant partnership program now
you're up to speed let's take a look at
the new developments on Friday Carlos
tweeted a video of himself confirming
that he had resigned from G2 Esports as
CEO I can't believe what I'm about to
say now but
um
my time in G2 has come to an end
which means that um I will be stepping
down from my CEO position
[Music]
um I you know I know it might be a
shocker for many of you or most of you
and
you know trust me this is a very hard
ending
to what has been otherwise a very
deeply meaningful and
joyful experience this was an incredibly
shocking development and members of the
Esports Community weighed in on the move
with many expressing disbelief for me
the shocks seemed to sweep away reality
for a moment like a G2 Esports without
Carlos
I hadn't really considered that this was
a possibility that might happen and it
seems like many other people didn't
consider that possibility either I
figured he returned from the eight week
break we'd get a more heartfelt apology
maybe talking about what he learned and
this whole thing would sort of settle
down I guess instead G2 announced that
Carlos had resigned although it's quite
possible someone say probable that he
was asked to do so especially given how
he talked about it in his tweet and
again trust me when I say
I just feel
destroyed about it you should know that
now the situation would have seemed
pretty unbelievable even a couple months
ago
CEO of G2 Carlos stepping down and his
org continuing on without him I
mentioned this in my last video but G2
Esports are an incredibly talented group
of people and they made some of my
favorite content in the industry focused
around Esports players so in terms of
having the skills to continue succeeding
in Esports I have no doubt that they
will be fine still Carlos was a massive
part of G2 he was part chaotic Visionary
part Twitter antagonist part unofficial
mascot and I have no doubt that like
many Esports players Carlos will have
some fans that follow him to whatever he
does next but the recent leadership from
Carlos put the organization in a pretty
tough spot on the one hand I'm sure that
they would have preferred to just keep
him on board but losing the valorent
slot on its own is a huge potential
Financial loss and that's without even
discussing the fact that it costs a good
amount of money to even apply for the
thing I don't know exactly what the
process was like but if it was anything
like the process for franchising in the
LCS or LEC in League of Legends it was
extremely in-depth I mean like 100 page
applications created by marketing design
and writing professionals potentially
thousands of hours of Labor expended on
this one thing all of that was wasted in
an instant by Carlos and now the people
who were supposed to have jobs with g2's
Valor division maybe don't that includes
players by the way G2 was set to acquire
exet's valorant roster but those players
are now out of a job then add on all the
fans who are upset by Carlos's actions
the subsequent doubling down and his
non-apology that's damage to the brand
that's not easy to revert because Carlos
offered this non-apology and continued
to like tweets supporting Tate it's
actually wild that it ended like this in
the past it always seemed like Carlos
knew where the line was and if he didn't
he was willing to admit that and
regardless of your feelings on the
removal itself I think it's fair to say
that for most people this is a nearly
unforeseeable end to Carlos's time as
CEO frankly whatever your opinions on
Carlos and you are entitled to them I
think that he did a lot to push Esports
forward using his player's salary to
First Dream of and then build something
pretty incredible G2 Esports has been
one of the most important organizations
in so many titles they're boundary
pushing content and world's results in
League of Legends their Dynasty in
Rainbow Six Siege and their historic
roster sale and constant attempts to
reach the top in CS go Esports would
look a lot different without G2 Esports
and G2 Esports wouldn't exist without
Carlos but you probably don't have to
look around too hard to find the
likeliest reason that Carlos was removed
from his position his actions rep
presented a serious Financial threat to
the company now that doesn't mean that
there weren't people at G2 Esports or
Riot games that were genuinely upset by
Carlos's actions I'm positive that there
were it's not like everybody involved
has a zero personal convictions or
something when Riot decides to pass on
G2 for valorence franchising plans or G2
suspends Carlos those decisions are
almost certainly driven by money and
while neither company has the legal
obligation of a publicly traded company
since they are not publicly traded they
both have that same obvious incentive if
it was demonstrably more profitable to
keep Carlos where he was call me a cynic
but I have no doubt that they would the
people with the money also typically
expect you to fall in line when said
money is at risk and if you can't find
it deep within yourself to do that then
you're what a balance sheet would call a
liability okay so then should fans have
been outraged by that initial tweet I
think think that they have every right
to be but I can't really retread that
entire situation in this video I'd
recommend checking out our initial
Andrew Tate video or the Carlos tweet
video both hosted by yours truly if you
want more on that I'll get the links in
the description for you now I want to
move on to the question that has been
constantly asked this weekend was
Carlos's removal just like should he
have been removed for his actions and
unless it was unclear we're done with
the facts of the matter itself and on to
the discussion of the discussion if you
will now some people have tried to paint
this as getting fired for one tweet but
I think this misses the bigger picture
he tweeted something voluntarily doubled
down on it and then showed that he was
being forced to issue a statement that
he didn't want to issue he showed the
org and all its sponsors that he was a
potential liability and there didn't
really seem to be any remorse for his
actions only for the damage it inflicted
on the org that by the way he's still
owns a substantial portion of and now it
may not even be his a report today from
Esports maniacos claims that Carlos
doesn't own any of the organization now
after Riot told G2 that he was
blacklisted while we don't have a
Spanish speaker on staff to sift through
the 40-minute nuanced discussion it
appears that after Riot told G2 that
Carlos was blacklisted Carlos sold his
shares in G2 and stepped down as CEO
initial reactions seem to suggest that
riots specifically demanded that Carlos
sell but the later distinction that
emerged was that Riot blacklisted him
meaning that he couldn't be involved in
the team operations side but G2 then
asked him to divest this was noted by
League Caster medic on Twitter the exact
situation is not clear right now and we
invite any Spanish-speaking members of
our community to provide more context in
the comments below if you'd like okay
getting back back on track to talk about
the discussion other arguments have
blamed Carlos being fired on fans
tagging G2 sponsors and pointing up the
tape video this is an extremely weird
argument that I don't really get if you
think that these sponsors don't have
somebody that manages and follows these
deals then you're wrong they absolutely
do and they might even have known about
this whole situation before the first
person tagged BMW or Logitech now the
last thing I saw a lot of this weekend
were accusations of hypocrisy against
Carlos's critics in fact I'd argue that
this response was one of the most common
to his resignation first off if you can
prove someone is a hypocrite that's all
well and good but it doesn't actually
deal with the argument being discussed
that person might not be the best person
to make that argument but the argument
itself remains intact and somebody else
could just make the same argument
without the conflicts that that make
them a hypocrite now these accusations
were mostly directed at people working
for a company owned by Saudis being
owned in whole or in part by tencent or
working for Riot who has had massive
issues with workplace sexism and
misogyny now I can't believe I have to
say this but working at Riot games does
not mean that you can't have an opinion
on Andrew Tate the same is true of
someone working for ESL which is owned
by a public Saudi company or someone
working for tencent which of course has
links to China sure you can point out
the hypocrisy if you want like go nuts
actually it seems like you kind of
already did seems like you guys really
really dug into that one but if you
don't touch the argument
chickened out what fans can do is draw a
line on Tate and they did that's not bad
and it's not holier than thou or
something listen some people myself
included understand how much Carlos did
for Esports some people were personally
helped and reassured by a person that
gave them a start or a big break in this
industry but these new actions conflict
with that Legacy what Carlos did and
then doubled down on understandably
upset a lot of people and that doesn't
just get ignored because of his prior
contributions we can't really know what
beliefs Carlos shares with Tate if any
just based on this video Carlos is now
separated wife with whom he spent over
eight years did go on record to say that
she had never seen behavior that would
match the things that Tate Advocates
from Carlos Carlos did a lot for Esports
and the legacy of that Carlos will still
exist but at the same time time this
final episode of his time with G2 will
be a part of that Legacy too and that's
something that he his supporters and the
org that he founded will have to come to
terms with
man fall like just
came out of nowhere
you know one day I'm just wearing my
Persona shirt and then the next day I'm
wearing a plaid shirt over my Persona
shirt what what uh what a shocking turn
of events